[Musique]
non
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire la 5g la cinquième
génération de réseaux mobiles qui
devraient nous permettre de bénéficier
d'un meilleur débit et d'augmenter les
performances des appareils connectés
suscite la controverse 42000 antennes
doivent être déployés d'ici cinq ans les
enchères pour l'attribution de nouveaux
blocs de fréquences commenceront en
france le 29 septembre mais certains
s'inquiètent des frais que cela va
occasionner pour les futurs utilisateurs
mais aussi des conséquences sur la santé
et sur l'environnement
alors pour en débattre nous avons invité
gilles babinet qui est entrepreneur vice
président du conseil national du
numérique dont le rôle comme chacun sait
de conseiller le gouvernement vous êtes
également digital championne de la
france auprès de la commission
européenne vous êtes l'auteur de
transformation digitale l'avènement des
plateformes paru aux éditions le passeur
vous êtes pour ou contre le déploiement
de la 5g en france gilles babinet
je suis surtout pour parce que je pense
que c'est le sens de l'histoire que
c'est à peu près impossible de faire
fonctionner une économie moderne sans
cette technologie et je pense que on
peut avoir un certain nombre
d'observations et de réserves sur la
façon dont elle doit être implémenté de
sorte à ce que ça se fasse bien qu'un
salon des critiques qui sont émises soit
résolu
philippe bihouix vous êtes ingénieur
spécialisé dans les métaux et les
ressources naturelles votre dernier
livre c'est le bonheur était pour demain
les rêveries d'un ingénieur solitaire
c'est par une mission du seuil dans la
collection anthropocène vous vous êtes
pour ou contre le déploiement de la 5g
en france écoutez je suis plutôt contre
105 g ce qui fait de moi si j'ai bien
compris 1 1 à mich en fait je pense que
les coûts environnementaux sont
absolument direct et immédiat que ce
soit sur la consommation d'énergie ou
sur l'obsolescence qui sera du coin de 8
sur les équipements et par contre les
bénéfices environnementaux sont très
incertains ou même très lointain c'est à
dire ce que les nouveaux usages
5 g pourrait apporter certains de nos
secteurs comme le bâtiment la ville où
la mobilité mais mettront très longtemps
avant de générer des bénéfices
environnementaux voire dans les généraux
jamais d'où le rapport coûts bénéfices
qui implique donc de ne pas déployer la
5g christine balagué vous êtes
professeur titulaire de la chaire blood
in tech à la stib à institut mines
télécoms business school est une école
de commerce vous êtes également membre
du comité d'experts du csa sur la
désinformation en ligne membres de la
commission impact des recommandations de
la haute autorité de santé
vous vous êtes pour ou contre la scène
jeux en france l'avenir et je suis
favorable effectivement au développement
de lâche 5 g et la 5g illustre
aujourd'hui les enjeux des technologies
c'est à dire qu'on s'aperçoit essais
nous vous que les technologies bien sûr
peuvent être très positive mais bien sûr
aussi ont des impacts comme tout progrès
qui peuvent être négatif et donc il nous
faut des mesures il nous faut des
calculs d'impact environnemental il nous
faut des calculs d'un impact sociétal
des technologies ce que l'on cherche à
faire dans la chair d'in'tech que j'ai
développé donc oui au développement de
la 5g mais de manière responsable
nicolas bérard enfin vous êtes
journaliste vous êtes l'auteur de 5 g
mon amour enquête sur la face cachée des
réseaux mobiles s'est sorti au mois de
juin aux éditions le passager clandestin
pour ou contre la scène j'ai clairement
contre la 5g pour les raisons notamment
que vous avez cités c'est à dire les
questions d'ordre sanitaire et
environnementale
mais pas seulement en fait il ya aussi
des questions d'ordre social sociétal et
donc en fait si je suis opposé à la 5g
c'est contre la 5g et son monde
voilà et la notion même de progrès dont
je viens d'entendre perdre et de progrès
en fait pour moi la 5g ne répond pas du
tout un progrès ne correspond pas du
tout à cette notion de progrès alors il
faut rappeler que la 1 g la première
génération c'était le téléphone sans fil
la deuxième génération c'était de
rajouter du texte ça 2d les sms la 3g ça
a permis les photos la 4g ça a permis
les vidéos et
et les applis la 5g normalement ça va
nous apporter quoi
gilles babinet l'a5 je pense que il ya
une différence que l'on évoque assez peu
c'est une rupture de paradigme sur la
façon dont l' architecture de réseau
fonctionne je veux pas rentrer dans les
détails mais la raison pour laquelle on
a fait ça c'est que on pensait que tout
un tas d'acteurs notamment les acteurs
économiques
n'utilisez pas beaucoup les
infrastructures réseau parce qu'il ne
considérait pas assez fiable pas assez
flexibles pour leur usage
donc on rajoute sur la norme
relativement sophistiqué de la 5g ya
plusieurs volets le 1,5 g 20 seulement
on rajoute ce qu'on appelle les software
design network et qui vont permettre
réellement d'administrer une sous partie
du réseau de façon optimale et donc ce
qu'on pense il ya plusieurs études qui
vont dans cette direction c'est que à la
différence des versions précédentes la
5g va être massivement pour un usage
professionnel
donc les usages
que l'on peut avoir ses administrés un
bâtiment par exemple ou administrer les
équipements qui vont se trouver dans une
usine c'est pas du tout ce qu'on faisait
auparavant quand il y avait des robots
dans une usine systématiquement on les
calais sur des réseaux qu'on appelait
des réseaux synchrone ça c'est
absolument impossible de faire avec les
technologies de type 4g ou 3g et c'est
possible de le faire avec des
technologies 5 g donc il ya beaucoup
d'acteurs moi j'étais à une réunion du
mittelstand qui était un peu le patronat
allemand est à peu près un an il y à
beaucoup d'acteurs qui pensent que à
moyen terme
c'est à peu près impossible de faire
fonctionner les systèmes économiques
sans ce type de technologie et puis la
5g de façon plus classique c'est surtout
une accélération importante du débit
pour nous pour les usagers comme un qui
va se faire avec une architecture de
réseau qui permet de le faire et
notamment parce que on utilise un
spectre de fréquences qui est très
étendue sur trois trois zones de
fréquences et qui permet d'être optimale
on verra plus tard que en matière de
consommation d'énergie et de rayonnement
c'est aussi une grande amélioration
ribéry x oui bah je pense qu'en fait on
a un certain nombre d'usagés possibles
qui sont vraiment autour de trois
fonctionnalités
c'est d'ailleurs le résumé qu'en font
souvent les acteurs de la salle j ai la
possibilité en fait d'avoir un temps de
latence très faible c'est-à-dire un
temps d'activité extrêmement courts de
l'ordre de la microseconde ça ça peut
servir par exemple quand on pourrait
imaginer des voitures autonomes de 20 il
faut pouvoir réagir à quelle qu'elle
soit quelque part au piloter ou qu'elles
puissent interagir avec son nouvel
environnement manière extrêmement serré
et à la possibilité d'avoir un nombre de
connexions extrêmement élevé on parle de
l'ordre d'un million par kilomètre carré
c'est à dire un art m² et ça ça
permettrait à bâle le développement de
de l'internet des objets on dit la
guillotine internet of things en anglais
et puis un troisième élément qui est
effectivement sur un certain nombre de
fréquences cité gilles babinet sur un
des trois fréquences la possibilité
d'avoir une bande passante extrêmement
élevé et donc qui permet soit dotée de
faire l'état des téléchargements très
rapide ou ou d'avoir voilà faire des
choses comme de la réalité augmentée de
la réalité virtuelle qui vont demander
énormément de traitement de calcul et
d'allers retours entre le terminal de
l'utilisateur et puis les les
datacenters voilà essentiellement les
trois éléments qui fonctionne pas les
uns avec les autres
ensuite sur la consommation d'énergie on
viendra on va y passer un bon temps mais
juste pour qu'on se fasse tous une idée
de ce que ça pourrait apporter
technologiquement christine balagué
alors en termes d'usagé il ya des usages
très grand public qui touche au monde
notamment un des usages qui a beaucoup
de sens et dans le domaine médical donc
dans le domaine médical on peut faire
grâce à la 5g des opérations à distance
on peut faire on peut transmettre des
données notamment des irm par exemple
donc c'est très intéressant
on peut par exemple donc aux vies de
suivre des transferts de patients de
nous péter à la nôtre donc évidemment
c'est quand même une valeur ajoutée non
négligeable et puis il ya bien sûr dans
le domaine de la médecine beaucoup
téléconsultation qui ont explosé
d'ailleurs pendant confinement est
encore aujourd'hui on est en train de
mener une étude sur ce sujet et donc de
faciliter les contacts et les
consultations notamment dans les zones
blanches notamment dans les déserts
médicaux français
parallèlement je dirais à ce sujet
de la médecine il ya tous le domaine de
l'assistance aux personnes âgées à
domicile on sait que avec un certain
nombre d'objets connectés et bien on
peut prévoir des alertes soient aux
pompiers soit à des services médicaux et
donc assurer un suivi des personnes
âgées à domicile plus efficace bien
entendu et puis également de manière
industrielle et gilles babinet l'a dit
la 5g à hainaut riant de l'application
bien sûr dans le domaine des véhicules
autonomes on l'a dit tout à l'heure
là il faut une rapidité je dirais de
transfert de données et beaucoup de
données en même temps donc la 5g répond
tout à fait à ce besoin de réseaux
tonneau mais également des applications
dans le domaine de la gestion de
bâtiments surtout dans le domaine des
réseaux électriques et donc une
optimisation des dépenses d'énergie donc
un impact aussi quelque part là positif
de la 5g
si on veut imaginer des conséquences en
termes d'optimisation de dépenses
d'énergie et puis enfin on peut penser à
10000 ohb-system qui probablement
viendront mais des systèmes d' alerte
pour la coupe population comment on fait
par exemple il ya des français qui ont
développé ce type d'application comment
on fait pour alerter en guadeloupe en
martinique et bien toute l'épopée toute
la population de l'ouragan qui arrive
dans une demi-heure ou dans une heure et
bien la 5g cette rapidité de réseau
permet également de répondre à ce type
de d'application je rappelle juste que
c'est quasi temps réel
le débit est multiplié par dix et
les deux transmissions des données est
divisé par dix donc effectivement sur
les aspects purement techniques on
parlera des impacts sociétaux évidemment
tout à l'heure et bien purement
techniques et applicatifs
il me semble que effectivement il ya des
usages qui sont très intéressants et je
crois qu'il faut raisonner je
terminerais là sur ce point sur ce point
il faut raisonner aussi haut niveau bien
sûr internationale pourquoi on développe
la 5g en france ou en europe
parce que les chinois développe la scène
j'ai les américains développeurs de la
5g et qu'on ne peut pas imaginer je
devrais ne pas aller vers ces
technologies et bien sinon on a une
perte de compétitivité très forte de les
entreprises on va en parler dans un
instant mais nicolas bérard pour vous
qu'est ce que ça va apporter
technologiquement qu'il ait le potentiel
de la ffg mais je pense qu'on est déjà
en fait dans le piège qui est tendu par
les promoteurs de la 5g c'est à dire que
on nous donne comme ça tout un tas
d'applications qui pourront être révisés
et là on vient de citer l'exemple de la
médecine de la télémédecine et des
opérations qui pourront se faire à
distance
ok c'est une prouesse technologique
mais il faut à chaque fois en fait
recentrer le débat c'est à dire que
c'est pas entendable pour moi que le
progrès ce soit de pouvoir se faire
opérer à distance surtout quand ce
discours est tenu par un gouvernement
qui réduit les moyens accordés aux
hôpitaux qui réduit le personnel
hospitalier et on nous dit qu'on prend
soin de notre santé grâce à la 5g parce
qu'on pourra être opéré par un
chirurgien qui se trouvera à plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres de là donc c'est
ça à chaque fois recentrer le débat et
c'est pour ça que je vous disais au
dépôt des parcs c'est la notion même de
progrès qu'il faut interroger
oui c'est une prouesse technologique
mais est ce que c'est un progrès pour
notre société
moi je le pense pas et on peut
multiplier les exemples les exemples
comme ça si vous voulez je peux vous
parler de la voiture autonome quel
intérêt à la voiture autonome
sincèrement on nous dit c'est super
parce que vous montez dans un véhicule
qui vous prend du point haye qui vous
emmène au point b
vous n'allez pas besoin de conduire donc
vous pouvez faire autre chose en
attendant bon mais il existe des taxis
aujourd'hui la seule différence c'est
que dans un taxi il ya un chauffeur ça
crée un emploi et l'autre et différence
c'est qu'avec la voiture autonome on
remplace non seulement le corps du
chauffeur de taxi mais aussi son
intelligence
or pour remplacer cette intelligence il
va falloir quoi des milliers de capteurs
des antennes des transmissions
d'informations incessantes qui vont être
analysés en permanence par des
ordinateurs et tout ça consomme
énormément d'énergie
donc on voit cette opposition on peut on
retrouve très souvent dans les exemples
d'applications qui vont avec la 5g
on voit cette opposition entre le
développement économique
si je profiterai certainement à quelques
très grandes entreprises et le
développement humain alors bihouix est
ce qu'on peut vous le disiez tout à
l'heure faisant allusion à ce qu'avait
dit mais emmanuel macron je suis un ami
ch est-ce qu'on peut se permettre à
votre avis un pays comme le nôtre
aujourd'hui de ne pas faire le choix de
la 5g à partir du moment où tous nos
voisins et les plus grands des économies
du monde se mette à la 5g est ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer d'être le petit
village qui résistaient la 5g ce que ça
vous paraît viable
la question c'est est-ce qu'il faut
toujours copié ses voisins il me semble
qu'il ya des domaines où l'on compile
pas forcément la chine et les états unis
il me semble qu'on n'a pas installer de
nouvelles centrales à charbon par
exemple en france au prétexte que les
chinois installe donc moi je pense
qu'effectivement le le le la question
c'est est ce qu'on peut se permettre
d'installer la 5g aussi et je retourne
la question
d'abord sur la question ça sur le
l'aspect presque financier il faut
comprendre qu'aujourd'hui il ya
évidemment des gens qui poussent à
l'installation de la saint jean entre
autres les équipementiers
alors il n'a pas de nom n'a pas de
français il ya nokia ericsson qui sont
dans l'ordre de l'europe puis ensuite on
a way that they eux et ça me saoule
encore et balises étaient en chine
eux ont un intérêt évidemment à vendre
et c'est bien naturel puisque le
déploiement 4g qui peu ralenti le
chiffre d'affaires mais les opérateurs
télécoms eux mêmes sont un petit peu
moins clair sur leur modèle économique
parce qu'en fait la question c'est
est-ce que effectivement on a des gens
ou des industries qui sont prêts à payer
pour ces services de 5 g qui vont être
extrêmement onéreux installé on a vu que
pour les particuliers le fait d'eux de
pouvoir télécharger son film en deux
secondes plus tôt qu en une minute et
peut-être quelque chose qui va être
difficile à valoriser et puis ensuite
tous les autres usages on va dire
industrielle au sens large basse et
c'est moins clair alors faites juste
prendre trois exemples parce que j'étais
bon en avant on les a déjà mentionné
alors sur la télémédecine
moi j'ai quand même du mal à croire que
je veux bien qu'on fasse de la télé
médecine voire même de la téléchirurgie
et j'ai quand même du mal à croire qu'on
va faire de la téléchirurgie dans des
camions mobiles dans les campagnes donc
pourquoi est ce qu'il faut aller
tartiner tout le tout nouveau réseau de
5 g il suffirait peut-être d'avoir tout
simplement de câbles et des hôpitaux en
fibre optique ce qui est déjà plus ou
moins le cas et on aura d'excellentes
connexions
idem sur sur les usines
alors oui je veux bien croire que de
certaines certaines usines qui
manipulent des millions de pièces
différentes comme des usines automobiles
puissent est intéressé par sa tante
d'applications liées à cette logistique
intelligente mais il faut comprendre
qu'une une antenne 2 5g ça a importé de
300 m pour celles qui ont un débit
important
donc vous pouvez tout à fait prendre une
musique qui fait un kilomètre et la
couvrir avec trois ou quatre antennes 5
g vous avez à nouveau pas besoin de
tartiner tout le pays idem sur la
voiture autonome la voiture autonome je
veux bien qu'elle arrive alors elles
risquent d'arriver un petit peu tard
parce que comme nicolas bérard le
mentionner en fait elle remplace du
travail humain où elle ne remplace pas
du travail humain c'est-à-dire soit il
ya pas de chauffeur de taxi ce passé-là
soit c'est la voiture de papa et maman
qui se transforme en bureau mobile alors
quand elle va remplacer du travail
humain c'est toute l'histoire de la
technologie
on se doute qu'à ce moment là ce qu'on
aura économisé sur la main d'oeuvre on
pourra se payer cette technologie
supplémentaires mais il est loin d'être
évident comme un homme que tout un
chacun que des millions d'automobilistes
puisse se payer cette sociaux coûts et
un grand patron de
d'un constructeur français qui avait dit
de la voiture autonome ce qu'ils feront
cela payer sont déjà assis sur le siège
arrière
voyez ce que je veux dire donc cette
question a donc le modèle économique est
loin d'être évident et les opérateurs
télécoms dont certains ont timidement
d'ailleurs demandé un moratoire c'était
une manière polie de dire ouh là là on
n'est pas sûr de notre coup
parce qu'aujourd'hui il faut voir que
les premiers pays compenser déployé cinq
juges pour ça la corée du sud ou à la
chine mais les opérateurs tirent la
langue
au point de demander des subventions
pour les coûts énergétiques il ya pas
mal d'arguments là gilles babinet qu'est
ce que vous répondez à philippe bihouix
oui non je trouve que c'est
effectivement c'est tout à fait
intéressant ce qu'il dit est pertinent
par ailleurs néanmoins si vous voulez je
pense qu'il faut avoir conscience que
lorsqu'on a commencé à implémenter les
réseaux internet
personne n'aurait jamais eu à l'idée que
finalement internet ferait un jour
tourner la planète aujourd'hui pour
ainsi dire tous les systèmes industriels
les systèmes de transport & supply chain
les systèmes de commerce sont connectés
à internet est un petit peu comme une
boutade je vous dirais que si on avait
pas internet c'est pas peut-être de deux
planètes et demie que l'on aurait besoin
mais plutôt de 4 ou 5
il ya des gains d'opportunités des gains
d'efficacité qui sont extrêmement
significatif permis par internet
j'ai un exemple le taux de remplissage
des camions en europe
il a monté de 14 % entre 2000 et 2020 et
la seule raison qui permet d'expliquer
cela c'est évidemment les systèmes
d'information qui sont de plus en plus
interconnecté donc c'est quelque chose
qui va pas arriver je suis j'ai lu à ce
genre de choses sur effectivement les
difficultés de mise en place des réseaux
5 g aujourd'hui dans un son de pays j'ai
même lu d'autres choses je pense que ça
c'est plus de nature à être favorables à
5 g qui est que on considère que les
implémentations 5 g qui ont été faits
dans un certain nombre de pays dont la
chine
sont presque des prototypes et
nécessiteront d'être démonté
prochainement pour être remplacés par
des implémentations entre guillemets
industriels la réalité c'est que vous
allez pouvoir beaucoup plus facilement
inscrire et d inscrire sur le réseau
géré des priorités gérer de la sécurité
a un coût qui sera bien plus inférieur à
ce qu'il a jamais été jusqu'à présent et
ça ça va permettre de faire des choses
qui n'étaient pas entre guillemets
prévues au programme cirque que vous
avez une certaine linéarité dans le
fonctionnement de l'économie
là vous avez avoir un effet de rupture
l'une des conséquences plausible je
n'affirme pas qu'elle est certaine et
elle est assez probable néanmoins c'est
le rapatriement d'un certain nombre de
nos parts d'activité industrielle on
s'aperçoit que sur certains segments
industriels
ça coûte moins cher de produire en
europe notamment parce que les
technologies qui permettent de mettre en
oeuvre les machines sont aujourd'hui
relocalise abl notamment grâce au cloud
voilà et si on arrive à je dirais porter
cette chaîne de valeur jusqu'à la
machine à l'intégrer à la machine pour
ainsi dire ça va être beaucoup plus
facile de rajouter de l'industrie ça
c'est pas des choses que je sors de mon
chapeau c'est vraiment des échanges que
j'ai avec des industriels un petit peu
partout en europe et qui me font
ressortir ces points là donc oui je je
crois - effectivement aux usages
extrêmement spectaculaire donc on parle
toujours de l'opération chirurgicale à
distance c'est très spectaculaire et
c'est sans doute pour ça que c'est
beaucoup utilisé la réalité c'est que ce
que va surtout faire la 5g sait gérer
des très très grande quantité de petits
objets
la guillotine et objets connectés avec
une grande efficacité
aujourd'hui si vous voulez rajouter un
objet connecté sur un réseau par exemple
dans une entreprise vous devez avoir
vous devez avoir un administrateur
réseau qui regardent le numéro de
l'objet qui décident de l'installer qui
décide de lui lui donner des priorités
etc
ça ça coûte extrêmement cher et l'une
des choses que l'on voit c'est que par
exemple un fabricant gros fabricants
industriels je prends sans embauche par
exemple il va mettre la puce singer dans
la machine et il va faire un deal avec
des opérateurs préalablement pour que
vous ayez rien à faire c'est connectés
in situ et vous pouvez l'installer dans
votre signe vous pouvez inscrire sur
votre réseau tout ça est extrêmement
facile à faire et donc vous pensez plus
les modèles économiques comme vous
voulez pensiez auparavant nicolas bérard
on sera plus facilement espionnage bhl
avec la scène jeu qu'avec la 4g abat
clairement à partir du moment où tout et
tout est connecté
évidemment on va laisser encore plus
d'informations que ce qu'on laisse
aujourd'hui il prévoit un million
d'objets connectés au kilomètre carré
donc je cite dans mon livre une
entreprise qui s'appelle entreprises
violet qui avait comptabilisé six mille
objets dans une maison donc autant vous
dire qui comptabilise absolument tout et
à l'époque c'était en 2012 il comptait
que trois objets connectés et le
téléphone la télévision et l'ordinateur
et les disait il nous en reste donc 5
1997 à connecter moi j'ai l'impression
quand j'entends parler des avantages de
la 5g c'est qu'on n'est pas du tout dans
le dans le bon débat quoi c'est à dire
quand on arrondit les angles d'un
système qui qu'on peut résumer comme le
système capitaliste dont on sait qu'il
va falloir sortir et on nous explique on
va avoir des petits gains en remplissant
un peu plus les camions etc
je pense qu'on ne s'est pas du tout à la
hauteur des enjeux alors après je si si
je vais plus loin dans mon raisonnement
je vous expliquerai que ça va le faire
même
qu'aggraver sait les dégâts
environnementaux
mais admettons que ça arrondit c'est un
peu les angles du système capitaliste
enfin je veux dire la question à se
poser c'est pourquoi on a besoin
d'autant de camions qui transportent des
marchandises d'un bout à l'autre de la
planète et il va falloir au bout d'un
moment regarder le sujet en face et se
dire qu'il faut changer radicalement de
système et je pense que c'est pour ça
que emmanuel macron s'est tendu au temps
et qu'il a caricaturé ses opposants les
opposants à la 5g en les traitant
damisch pour moi j'ai rien contre les
amish mais apparemment pour lui c'est
une autre c'est une insulte
parce que justement il n'y a pas
d'alternative c'est à dire que tout le
système qu'il défend en fait se
restructure autour de 7,5 g et de cette
société hyper connectés et là où il
retourne où il est assez fort et
retourne finalement l'argument c'est que
il fait croire que les opposants à la 5g
sont contre le progrès il aurait pu
employer une autre expression qu'il a
utilisée avec quelques temps en les
traitant de gaulois réfractaires bon
mais en fait les autres ça a buggé bon
ben je vous propose de faire une pause
on se retrouve juste après et on
continue ce débat y compris avec nicolas
behra
[Musique]
quelle reprise économique pour l'après
qu'ovide 19 à quoi peut-on s'attendre on
a été dans l'oeil du cyclone cet été en
fait ça fait à peu près trente ans que
la croissance structurelle en france
baisse
donc elle va continuer à être au mieux
médiocre et au pire catastrophique les
prévisions que peuvent faire le fmi ou
la deutsch bank a cédé prévisions au
doigt mouillé ça n'a pas grande valeur
si l'état était capable de vraiment
c'est l'économie la france elle prit
plus développés du monde beaucoup de
pays était déjà en récession donc le coc
vide n'a été qu'un catalyseur en fait de
ce qui s'est passé pour qu'une économie
croise il faut que ceux qui prennent des
risques gagne plus d'argent que ceux qui
en prennent pas parler de croissance car
on prend toutes les mesures qu'il faut
pour que les entrepreneurs ne gagne pas
d'argent c'est un peu pas bien sérieux
dans les bancs où la diversité c'est
notre point fort pas notre point faible
ce que j'ai vu depuis le 17 octobre et
depuis aussi le 4 août c'est une
mobilisation sociétal qui n'existait pas
avant toutes les confessions se
retrouver sur la place des martyrs a
certes chohada et tout le monde discute
est finalement dumont discuter ils sont
trouvés entre le même drapeau libanais
pour une fois des images assez touchants
de l'armée qui était presque impliqué
avec les manifestants aujourd'hui on
sent que le ton a changé c'est la cause
d un politique et sont en train de
manipuler l'armée on sait très bien
pourquoi ils nous tirent dessus c'est
pas s'ils savent que c'est leur fin ils
se préparent le seul langage qu'ils
connaissaient la violence il ne va pas
être violent et on va rester
[Musique]
repro ce débat sur la 5g avec gilles
babinet qui est vice-président du
conseil national du numérique avec
philippe bihouix qui est ingénieur avec
christine balagué qui est titulaire de
la chaire goulding tkm tbs et nicolas
bérard mais nicolas bérard on l'a perdu
et on espère bien le retrouver les
journalistes c'est l'auteur de 5 g mon
amour enquête sur la face cachée des
réseaux mobiles de là à ce que l'un des
pourvoyeurs de la 5g les couper le tuyau
qui le relier à nous il n'y a qu'un pas
en attendant ben parlons justement de
cet impact environnemental dont les
adversaires bleus voilà nicolas bay avec
bon retour nicolas est alors allons
venons en à l'impact environnemental
philippe bihouix vous aviez beaucoup à
dire sur ce sujet la 5g ce serait pas
bon pour l'environnement
non effectivement je confirme maintenant
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que en
général et les promoteurs de la 5g nous
parle d'efficacité énergétique et donc
du fait que pour transporter la même
quantité de l'information le même nombre
d'octets on a cinq j-20 effectivement
permettre de l'utiliser beaucoup moins
d'énergie que la 4g aujourd'hui ce qui
est une réalité
alors on sait pas encore exactement
combien parce que effectivement ya
encore des choses qui sont un petit peu
en en expérimentation en optimisation et
mais en tout cas c'est à peu près sûr
que lauren très grande efficacité
énergétique
le problème ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que les réseaux en fait sans pile
c'est à dire que l'arrivée de la 5g ne
va à remplacer la 4g ou la 3g ou la 2g
qui sont d'ailleurs toujours là parce
qu'un certain nombre d'applications
industrielles qui sont liés donc en fait
on va rajouter un réseau ce réseau en
fait on estime qu il
configuration équivalente qui devrait
consommer de l'ordre de 3 fois le réseau
4g 3g 4g actuelle alors ce sont des
estimations
ça dépendra en fait de la configuration
du déploiement du réseau et des
arbitrages qui peut y avoir entre des
antennes de grande portée et avec un
débit plus faible et des antennes de
petite portée avec un débit plus fort
mais voilà on va dire qu'en france ça
doit être de l'ordre de deux ennemis ou
trois fois plus et malgré tout il ya
cette efficacité énergétique et en fait
d'où vient-elle
elle vient du satané effet rebond c'est
à dire que là encore toute l'histoire de
technologies montre que à chaque fois
qu'on est plus efficace et bien en fait
on consomme plus quand même à la fin
parce qu'on va parce qu'on va utiliser
plus souvent avec le service il est tout
à l'heure j'ai deux vous parliez de
l'optimisation qui a été permise au
niveau du transport routier en europe
par le gps en fait et par les
applications numériques qu'ils sont
libres pour le taux de remplissage s'est
parfaitement vrai mais on n'a jamais eu
autant de camions sur nos routes quand
même dire que le l'amélioration du taux
de remplissage a pas réduit le nombre de
camions qui roulent sur les routes mais
elle a même augmenté pourquoi il a
augmenté parce qu'il a permis que les
services de transport soient moins chers
et donc il ya plus de trafic interurbain
il ya plus d'éloignement entre les lieux
de consommation et des lieux de
production
donc voilà on sait que la facture
énergétique seller en france après de
l'ordre de 10 térawattheures milliards
de kilowattheures sert pour faire simple
quelques va dire 2 2 tranches nucléaires
à peu près en un petit peu moins
peut-être en équivalent en équipements
de production
et puis il ya un autre volet qui est
très important dans le numérique
puisqu'en fait une partie importante
quand vous tenez votre mobile entre les
mains l'aller 81 90 % de la consommation
d'énergie qui est le sac à dos
écologique c'est-à-dire ce que le ce qu
il a déjà fallu consommer pour produire
votre votre terminal et ensuite
seulement 10 à 20% qui vont être
réellement lié à l'utilisation de ce
terminal est bien évidemment la 5g va
provoquer une obsolescence massive des
terminaux alors on sait que de toute
manière le consommateur est bien changer
de temps en temps sur smartphone mais ça
va un petit peu tendance à se ralentir
pour une fois et là on va ré accéléré
pour créer une nouvelle vague
d'équipement et donc à l'échelle
mondiale
par 2 milliard de smartphones plus tous
les équipements plus tous les deux
acteurs derrière donc effectivement on
va embarquer un coût écologique très
important qu'elle c'est une blague et je
pense plus globalement qu'on est en fait
à une nouvelle ère des technologies
c'est à dire que c'est la fin de ce
qu'on appelle le solutionner
technologique on développe des
technologies pour répondre à des
questions pour pour répondre à des
problèmes particuliers
non aujourd'hui ces technologies
lorsqu'elles sont comme c'est le cas
pour la 5g extrêmement disruptive pour
les utilisateurs lorsqu'elles toussent
des infrastructures nationales
lorsqu elle génère des questions
sociétales et bien c'est ce type de
technologie doit être pensée de manière
responsable voire éthique et donc dans
la chair que j'ai développée entre
l'institut min et les commissions
secours qui s'appelle good in tech
eh bien c'est exactement ce travail que
l'on fait avec surtout technologies un
calcul qui n'est pas simple bien sûr un
double calcul un calcul d'impact
environnemental de la technologie et un
calcul bien sûr d'impact sociétale de la
technologie alors sur l'impact
environnemental ça a été dit mais
finalement pourquoi il ya le débat
aujourd'hui il ya le débat parce qu on
n'a pas de chiffres précis
il y en a pas de chiffre précis et
pareil pour l'impact sociétal
parce que finalement la cinquième n'est
pas déployé donc
on n'arrive pas à savoir réellement
finalement qu'est ce que ça donne on a
quelques exemples un peu en corée mais
on a quand même très peu de chiffres et
donc ce type de technologie de mon point
de vue devrait être quand même tester
avant d'être déployé elle devrait être
testé sur un territoire avec des mesures
extrêmement précises d'impact
environnemental et l'impact sociétal
on reviendra peut-être sur l'impact
société tout à l'heure alors sur le plan
environnemental il ya plein de paradoxes
c'est à dire que effectivement certains
disent un mail à 5 g
finalement est une amélioration par
rapport à laquelle j'ai la 3g et les
technologies précédentes ce qui est réel
et donc 7,5 g et moins consommatrices
d'énergie on peut faire un parallèle
très simple une voiture moderne et bien
et moins polluante on sait bien qu'une
voiture qui a une vingtaine d'années où
la 25ème donc le grand public peut tout
à fait comprendre ce point là même temps
effectivement ça va demander de nouveaux
appareils ça va demander des équipements
et c'est là où en fait on a 80 %
effectivement ça vient d'être dit de
dépenses énergétiques et donc ce calcul
de finalement l'impact des changements
des terminaux sur l'impact et
énergétiques de la 5g et bien pour
l'instant on n'en sait rien ça n'est pas
reculer je dirai aussi que effectivement
on a un paradoxe dans les usages de la
5g
vous avez par exemple un réseau très
utilisés par les jeunes aujourd'hui un
réseau social qui s'appelle instagram
qui consomment principalement des photos
voir des vidéos où il est évident
qu'avec la 5g et bien les jeunes vont au
bout les moins jeunes vont encore plus
utilisé instagram les photos et les
vidéos et donc il suffirait peut-être
d'arrêter ses usages qui sont
extrêmement polluant pour peut-être et
bien profiter d'une 5 g qui sera
appliquée dans un cadre industriel pour
développer certains emplois pour encore
une fois permettre un certain nombre de
je dirais d'amélioration dans le domaine
médical ou dans des industries qui ont
vraiment du sens ou de l'impact
voilà donc pour moi il ya vraiment un
paradoxe mais ce qui manque
très concrètement aujourd'hui c'est ce
calcul d'impact réel environnement d'un
de la 5g tenant compte de tous les
éléments qu'on vient de citer nicolas
behra alors l'impact environnemental et
sociétal
vous abordez les les deux aspects dans
votre livre dans votre livre enquête
alors qu'en est il à votre avis l'impact
environnemental voilà enfin je crois
qu'on a eu les réponses
en fait c'est pas un projet qui est
pensé pour l'environnement c'est bon
lance un projet et après on étudie les
effets qui peut avoir positifs ou
négatifs sur l'environnement
donc à mon avis on prend encore le
problème à l'envers on devrait d'abord
voir ce que ça donne d'un point de vue
énergétique
et c'est pas anodin du tout pour pour se
rendre compte
le numérique représente aujourd'hui 3 7%
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
c'est autant que le trafic aérien
et si on continue sur cette lancée là
dans cinq ans ça aura doublé si on veut
respecter ou se donner une chance de
respecter les accords de paris qui
doivent limiter le dérèglement
climatique limiter seulement un jeu
insiste il faudrait que le numérique
baisse de 5% au minimum chaque année ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre donc
on est complètement à côté de la plaque
et quand on dit ensuite qu'on pourrait
annuler arrêté certains certains usages
comme les réseaux sociaux
c'est juste pas possible ça revient à
dire qu'on va construire des autoroutes
en interdisant les voitures de rouler
dessus
si on construit des autoroutes c'est
pour faire rouler des voitures dessus
donc plus on ira de bande passante et
plus cette bande passante sera utilisé
les je sais plus quel chef d'entreprise
qui disait construisent et nous les
tuyaux et nous on les remplira donc la
5g si elle est construite va créer un
boom l'effet rebond dont parlait
philippe bihouix on parle d'un d'une
augmentation des échanges de données qui
comprise entre 100 et 1000 dons
on échangerait entre 100 fois plus est
mille fois plus de données actuellement
avec la 2g la 3g la 4g si on
construisait la 5g l'impact
environnemental pour moi est
indiscutable et là on s'en tient juste
aux dépenses énergétiques
mais on pourrait aussi parler des
extractions minières que ça va susciter
parce qu'évidemment comme le projet
s'est lui aussi de connecter l'ensemble
des objets qui nous entourent on va être
bombardé publicité pour nous inciter à
acheter
le frigo connecter les couches connecter
les baskets connecter tout est déjà dans
les cartons est prêt à nous être vendus
gilles babinet
en plus il faudra aller aider déterrer
des métaux rares pour pouvoir faire
fonctionner tous ces objets connectés
donc là aussi l'impact va être terrible
si vous le dites mais je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup à dire j'ai trouvé vraiment
intéressant c'est ses points de vue qui
se sont exprimés j'essaie de revenir
rapidement dessus sur sur la
consommation structurelle des réseaux il
ya deux choses il ya d'abord il ya un
phénomène qui est bien connue qui
s'exprime depuis bientôt 50 ans qui
s'appelle la loi de moore qui fait que
les technologies ont une sorte d'
efficacité propre qui s'améliore en
permanence et vous le voyez très bien
puisque si je compare la consommation
d'anti smartphone ici avec ce que
faisait mon pc il ya une vingtaine
d'années mon pc et consommer 400 watts
c'est à dire des dizaines de fois plus
de ce smartphone
ça c'est une tendance qui continue sous
différentes formes
mais il ya un autre aspect qui n'est pas
évoquée et qui est quand même important
c'est gelé dit tout à l'heure il ya des
ruptures technologiques majeures dans l'
architecture de la 5g
je vous en donne deux
l'advanced sound flipmode qui fait que
entre deux émissions de paquets de
données ce fonctionne par paquet on est
capable de couper les équipements il ya
certains travaux qui sont des travaux
indépendants de recherche qui parle
d'une économie possible sur les
équipements sur les bts sur l'image que
vous avez derrière vous qui serait de
jusqu'à 60 %
c'est pas notre c'est extrêmement
significatif et puis le deuxième c'est
les antennes lanthane qu'on est
caractéristique qui sont totalement
nouvelles par rapport à ce qu'elle avait
auparavant l'une d'entre elles c'est
d'être directionnelle ce qui fait que
auparavant vous aviez des abat-jour qui
envoient entre guillemets des ondes dans
toutes les directions pour attraper le
mobile où qu'ils soient
maintenant c'est plutôt des lampes de
poche vous éclairer dans la direction du
du mobile et donc vous en voyez beaucoup
beaucoup moins d'énergie vous consommez
moins vous rayonnez - et puis ces
antennes elles sont aussi appropriée au
contexte dans lequel elles se trouvent
si vous êtes dans un contexte très très
haute densité on va mettre ce qu'on
appelle des nano celle les petites
antennes en très grand nombre qui
permettra d'envoyer une petite quantité
d'énergie pour rejoindre le mobile avec
une bande de fréquences qui sera
approprié à ce type d' usage et mine de
rien c'est une rupture très forte c'est
que quand on a fait la 4g on n'a pas
pensé comme ça ni la 3g d'air on a pensé
à peu près sûr l'achitecture qui
préexistait depuis l'émergence des
réseaux cellulaires et ça je crois que
ça mérite d'être dit pas ce que ça va
pas apparaître dans les mois qui vont
venir
mais à moyen terme ça à voir ça va avoir
un impact extrêmement conséquent sur les
réseaux je ne vous garantirais pas que
ça va réduire la consommation d'énergie
mais je dirais que c'est par honnêteté
et c'est pas du tout exclu que s'arrête
la région la réduisent de façon
extrêmement significative sur sur les
externalités
je crois que c'est voilà à christine
balagué l'a parfaitement dit on ne
mesure pas ces externalités c'est que
quand on voulu par les dégâts du
numérique on vous dit voilà les terres
rares la consommation d'énergie le
rayonnement mais on ne regarde pas les
externalités que ça produit commencer à
voir quelques travaux qui sortent à cet
égard je les salue parce que je pense
qu'on va se rendre compte que désirent
les externalités sont absolument massive
et puis sur les terminaux je suis pas
d'accord avec ce qui a été dit lorsqu'on
l'a la 3g pas d'études sur la 4g mais je
pense qu'elle va être pareil a été
implémenté on avait un cycle de
renouvellement des terminaux à l'époque
était de 24 mois et on assure on a
assisté à une accélération qui a
descendu pendant l'année
d'implémentation de la 3g
ce cycle à 18 mois donc finalement un
impact relativement faible aujourd'hui
le cycle de renouvellement des terminaux
en france il est de 31 mois
les terminaux qu'on vous vend
aujourd'hui sont déjà 5 gérer 10 et donc
je ne pense pas ça va avoir un impact
aussi considérable qu'on le dit et puis
j'ajoute que par obligation légale la
commission impose aujourd'hui que les
appareils électroniques soient recyclés
on est un taux qui est inférieur à
l'exigence de la commission qui souhaite
que ce soit 80% d'ici 2025
mais ça veut dire que on va moins
chercher des terres rares en afrique et
on va beaucoup plus les chercher dans le
terminal que vous avez recycler ces
phénomènes sont encore une fois
extrêmement complexe c'est plus
l'économie d'auparavant où vous aviez un
output productifs qui était extrêmement
simple à calculer s'est massivement
multi factorielle mais je finirai en
vous disant que je pense avoir une
sensibilité écologique extrêmement forte
et que si je considérais que les impacts
étaient négatifs du progrès en général
et la 5g en particulier mais je pense
que je n'hésiterais pas à le dire je
pense qu'un des enjeux c'est
effectivement en sous jacent je pense
que nicolas bérard l'a exprimé c'est une
finalement un affrontement modèle en
heureux les gens qui croient au progrès
qui croient que la technologie peut être
orienté vers l'environnement
ce que je pense et des gens qui ont été
prolongées un peu caricaturée par le
président mais je rattacherait plus à
l'école de pierre rabhi c'est à dire
qu'il pense que finalement il vaut mieux
retirer de la technologie si on veut
réussir à rejoindre les accords de paris
ce qui me semble absolument impossible
en tout cas impossible sans violence
parce que ça ne sera pas acceptée par
une majorité des terriens
alors il ya l'aspect environnemental on
vient de l'aborder mais aussi l'aspect
sanitaire est ce que ce serait dangereux
pour la santé ces ondes
électromagnétiques qui vont se
multiplier avec la 5g nicolas bérard
vous avez des choses à se dire là dessus
aussi
et vous lui dites dans votre livre oui
sur la santé ce qui est intéressant
après moi j'évite de rentrer dans la
controverse scientifique où on oppose
une étude à une autre une étude qui dit
qu'il n'y a pas de risque pour la santé
à une autre étude qui dit qu'il y avait
bel et bien des effets sur la santé
ce que j'observe c'est que les méthodes
utilisées par l'industrie du sans fil et
des nouvelles technologies orange en
règle générale sont exactement les mêmes
que les méthodes de lobbying employé
hier par l'industrie du tabac ou
l'industrie de l'amiante
voilà on retrouve exactement les mêmes
les mêmes schémas qui consiste à
produire notamment ce qu'on appelle
l'industrie du doute
donc où on finance l'industrie finance
elle-même une palanquée d'études qui
semble montrer qu'il n'y a pas d'effet
d'ordre sanitaire et à côté de ça on a
une une recherche publiques qui elles
quand elles en trouvent est prié de ne
pas le crier trop fort et on a même
retiré
là il ya deux ans il restait une taxe
une taxe que les opérateurs
téléphoniques devaient payer en fonction
du nombre d'antennes dont il dispose sur
le territoire et qui permettait de
financer de la recherche publique sur
les effets sanitaires des rayonnements
électromagnétiques
c'était pas grand chose un haut niveau
financiers pour réciter quelques
centaines de milliers d'euros mais ça
permettait cet argent été fléchés et
donc on était sûr de pouvoir produire un
minimum de recherche publics sur cette
question sanitaire
cette taxe a été supprimé donc
aujourd'hui en france on a plus aucune
plus aucun financement destiné à la
recherche sur la santé est en rapport
avec les ondes électromagnétiques et
juste pour finir je vais quand même
citer une étude parce que c'est une des
plus importantes qui a été réalisé elle
a duré dix ans elle a été réelle
réalisée par le bnd tipi qui est la
principale agence sanitaire des
etats-unis
elle a coûté 25 millions de dollars elle
a duré dix ans elle a porté sur 1200
rats bref c'est une des études les plus
complètes qui a été fait à ce jour
et cette étude conclut sur une preuve
évidente
je cite je cite l'étude sur une preuve
évidente qu'il existe un lien entre le
développement de certains cancers et
l'exposition aux ondes de la téléphonie
mobile
voilà et par ailleurs je rajoute juste
une dernière chose c'est que je
rencontre de plus en plus de gens qui
sont malades des ondes qui se disent
malade des ondes qui jusqu'à présent ont
été traités de chou je pense que là il
commence à être trop nombreux pour qu'on
mette tous pour tout le monde pour qu'on
puisse tous les traités de fous et il va
falloir prendre vraiment en compte ce
problème de santé publique philippe
bihouix ce sujet c'est pas ma spécialité
mais je constate simplement qu'il ya
effectivement sont un déficit d'études
indépendante et sans doute à une analyse
moins poussées sur l'indépendance des
chercheurs par rapport à l'industrie qui
est pas aussi poussée par un peu dans le
domaine pharmaceutique bon il y à aussi
quand même un certain de scientifiques
qui qui s'inquiètent alors parfois des
antennes des insectes qui chauffe dans
certaines fréquences par exemple ce sera
sans doute le 26 juillet donc pas celui
qui sera utilisé en premier mais je
pense qu'effectivement on on n'a pas
aujourd'hui de deux conséquences
sanitaires direct est visible évidemment
et de scandales du type amiante en
attente mais par définition c'est un peu
comme sur la question de l'exposition un
certain nombre de produits chimiques
c'est le sexe c'est peut-être l'effet
mille feuilles ou l'effet combinatoire
qui finira pas poser problème donc
effectivement chacun chaque couche qu'on
va rajouter est à nouveau je rappelle
que les réseaux sans fil et ne se
remplace pas et bien autant ciellement
facteurs de risques après c'est vrai que
c'est très difficile d'estimer les
risques au jour alors il ya un rapport
qui doit être rendu en 2021 en mars je
crois est d'ailleurs le ministre de la
santé avait demandé au premier ministre
qu'il fallait pas peut-être attendre ce
rapport avant de de se lancer dans la
dans la salle j'ai voulu intervenir
gilles babinet oui je pense ce sujet et
quand même vraiment qu'elles sont on n'a
pas à ma connaissance alors je ne
connais pas ces études américaines mais
d'études épidémiologiques sérieuse qui
aboutit à un lien entre le rayonnement
et des pathologies
il ya une étude qui célèbre financé par
l'union européenne l'étude interphone
qui a suivi des patients sur une dizaine
d'années et qui continuent d'ailleurs
parce que on considère qu'on a besoin
d'un complément je suis pense qu'il est
indispensable de faire la recherche
mathieu mais pour le moment et je
rappelle qu'il ya quand même sur terre
aux alentours de 6 milliards de
personnes qui utilisent des téléphones
mobiles je pense qu'on verrait
apparaître quelque chose dans les
chiffres s'il y avait un risque à
l'égard du rayonnement et surtout ce que
je pense important de dire et ça c'est
vraiment important c'est que la première
conséquence cas ce nouveau paradigme en
matière d'architecturé de réseau c'est
moins de rayonnement vers les individus
serre que si vous avez trois bandes de
fréquences qui sont attribués c'est pour
pouvoir être optimisé en fonction du
lieu où trouver et les les pics l'aude
les cas où vous recevez beaucoup de
rayonnement notamment parce que vous
êtes prêt d'une bts qui étaient des cas
problématiques auparavant notamment avec
la 2g vont disparaître progressivement
avec l'implémentation la 5g là là où il
ya un point et je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec philippe braud x c'est
qu'effectivement on devrait
progressivement des commissionné les la
2g
il ya un son de pays qui envisagent de
le faire de données des terminaux 3 ou 4
g à ceux qui ont des terminaux de g mais
factuellement c'est moins de rayonnement
vers les utilisateurs et même les non
utilisateurs
le fait de migrer progressivement vers
le singe et donc sur ce point là c'est
tout bénéfice je pense pour chacun
d'entre nous quelle c'est une blague est
ce qu'on arrive à sur ce type de
technologie encore une fois traitées
disruptive et tous sont les
infrastructures à une limite de
l'acceptabilité des populations et on
voit bien en france on le voit bien
partout et c'est paradoxal
et c'est tout à fait légitime cette
cette réaction des populations du sénat
et même des politiques pour certains en
fait on est dans un paradoxe un monde
dans lequel on développe des
technologies
parce qu'effectivement on pense que
c'est du soliste sionisme technologique
encore une fois on répondait à des
questions à des problèmes c'est pour
l'industrie
et paradoxalement on oublie complètement
l'utilisateur final
je prends l'exemple des objets connectés
combien vous diront que finalement la
valeur ajoutée d'un objets connectés
tels que il est présenté sur un marché
donc pensé par l'industrie n'est pas du
tout et j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur ce
sujet la valeur ajoutée perçue par les
individus par le citoyen et donc on a un
espèce de gap entre une offre qui
arrivent sur le marché et la valeur
ajoutée qui est perçu par les individus
et s'additionnent à cette
incompréhension ou en tout cas cette
vision tout à fait différente et bien
les deux sujets dont on a parlé et qui
est l'impact environnemental et l'impact
sanitaire
donc l'impact sanitaire je ne
commenterai pas longtemps parce que de
mon point de vue le sujet n'est pas la
réalité le sujet pourquoi on a pas
d'étude et donc il faut absolument que
des recherches encore une fois se
développe sur ce sujet et le
gouvernement devrait financer des
recherches indépendantes de la nerfs sur
effectivement l'impact de la cndh g en
termes sanitaires la seule limite de
tout ça c'est que c'est facile à dire
mais il faut des années de données pour
arriver à avoir effectivement des
résultats si l'étude qui vient d'être
cité tout à l'heure à cette étude porte
sur 10 en données
mais le point que je voulais soulevé
c'est que on a quand même oublier un
sujet majeur jusqu'à présent dans ce
débat qui est l'impact sociétal au
niveau des données et il me semble que
là on a des informations et là on a un
impact très très important on a des
données avec la 5g qui sont des données
massives en temps réel en temps réel on
a des millions d'objets connectés à
l'idéal d'une infrastructure cng qui
remonte dans un plat qui remonte et qui
donne beaucoup d'informations
sur la vie quotidienne des gens sur
évidemment qu'on marche des usines pour
ma marche des hôpitaux etc
mais sur le grand public on a énormément
donné qui remonte en temps réel et donc
on peut imaginer que tout individu va se
retrouver avec la 5g dans un cloud avec
un clone de données on pourrait
l'appeler le data clown et donc se pose
tout un tas de questions
la protection de ces données qui a axé
sur ces données le clat on sait qu'on
n'a pas beaucoup de clubs européens
donc le cloud américain est il suffisant
et on sait bien que non pour
effectivement protéger les européens par
rapport à l'usagé de ces données on sait
bien qu'avec tout un tas de croisement
de données et bien on peut arriver à
avoir beaucoup d'informations y compris
des informations santé y compris des
informations très intime sur les
individus et donc c'est je dirais c'est
ces questions sont quand même assez
légitime
aujourd'hui c'est à dire là l'impact
potentiel des données de la 5g sur les
individus et le nom on parle quand il a
faim malheureusement ce que karina je
suis obligé de vous interrompre
l'émission se termine
je vous remercie tous les quatre d'y
avoir participé
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]